[Music]
the u.s. is about to get more involved
in the Syrian conflict despite saying
this in 2013 I will not put American
boots on the ground in Syria Obama says
US Special Forces will now be on the
ground advising Kurdish fighters okay so
why the change in the last month there's
been a major development in Syria
beginning on September 30th Russia began
bombing more than 1,600 targets in the
country those strikes have killed 185
civilians 131 Isis fighters and 279
rebels like the US which began bombing
Syria last year Russia says it's
targeting what it calls terrorists but
the two countries seem to have a
different idea of who the terrorists are
over the last month this is where US
bombs have been dropped mostly on
territory controlled by Isis and this is
where Russian bombs have landed during
the same time mostly near the front
lines where the Syrian government and
the rebels who want to overthrow it are
fighting Russia is one of President
Assad's biggest allies so it's not
really a surprise that the majority of
its airstrikes have been targeting the
rebels including some that are supported
by the United States so far Russia's
involvement hasn't led to major gains
for the Syrian army but it's definitely
strengthened its position on the
battlefield an asset victory goes
against what the US says at once in
Syria which is probably why it's getting
more involved on the ground meanwhile
the Russian campaign has had another
impact off the battlefield
it's reignited the political
conversation about the future of Syria
several countries backing different
sides in the war met to discuss a way
out on Friday and crucially both Iran
and Russia Assad's biggest supporters
were at the table the problem is nobody
can agree on what should happen to asset
but the fact that all these sides are
talking could count as progress the only
people missing from these talks actual
Syrians can there be a real solution
without them
[Music]